hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to a new portion of the show I
like to call Raiders of the story this
is where I take a popular nostalgic show
and look over the first few episodes to
see if it still holds up with that said
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles as you all
know I love Ninja Turtles growing up I
was a here on a half-shell junkie but
now that I'm older is the show really as
good as I remember it
we know the movies definitely have flaws
but what about the television show that
turned these reptiles in the household
names
I mean after they were already household
names well I'm gonna look at the first
episodes to find out the ones from the
three VHS is that we all watched in the
80s and 90s so let's not waste any time
and start with turtle tracks
[Music]
here we go the very first episode of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles it starts
out in New York City the crime wave is
high with monkeys mysterious and of
course the reporter leading the story on
these crimes is good old April O'Neil
ninjas oh I just remember the reasons I
love her so much
one other left and one on the right
these incisions could only have been
made with a samurai sword and look at
this rope this can only be the work of
ninjas the ancient band of Japanese
warriors and how can you tell that from
the Rope professor well look for
yourself it's made in Japan whoa that
shut me up so we see the shredder
watches the reporters through a secret
camera as he sends the cast of Mad Max
the musical to put a stop to their story
we got a message for you from the big
boss man he wants you should stick to
reportin fashion shows
here
bullshit repressed that big wouldn't be
able to fit the pipe from Super Mario
Brothers but unfortunately she forgot
that she can't go through fucking walls
and gets herself Court sign often time
Neil oh but of course our green friends
come to safer as April can't believe her
eyes I don't know who you are but thanks
you're not human I can't handle this
so she wakes up in the turtles home it
passes out again I wish you'd stop doing
that
well she wakes up for a second time the
Turtles Master a rat named splinter
explains who they are
the story of my young friends and I is
really the story of a man named Hamato
Yoshi
he says his name used to be a motto
Yoshi and he was the master of a martial
arts clan known as the foot in Japan too
until his enemy named Naraku sake
literally stabbed him in the back
[Music]
so you plot to kill our honorable sensei
their sensei who looks like a scrotum
massage ball looks over the situation
and says throw the bomb out in disgrace
Yoshi fled to America penniless he was
forced to live in the sewers wait a
minute why did he go directly to the
sewers their shelters in New York and if
he's penniless how'd he get to America
in the first place and why doesn't he
get a job
those last two sentences are really
flawed okay so while living in the
sewers with the rats four baby turtles
drop down the drain and he decides to
take care of them as well he seems to
live a decent life most likely stealing
everything he possesses but then he
arrives home to a shock it was a
powerful mutagen this is back in the day
when science goo could just do anything
you can make up the most absurd
reasoning that has no scientific logic
but it's science good so it flies for
example let's see what happens if I take
this jar philadelphia cream cheese and
pour some science goo all over it
always turns into a 12-inch talking doll
of Dennis Miller science fucking sucks
man sighs fucking sucks hey what if
those crop circles were just ads for
target so since the turtles had most
recently been in contact with splinter
they turned human and since splinter
head was recently been in contact with
the Turtles he turns into a rat hey okay
he names them after the great
Renaissance painters because lord knows
this show has to teach kids something it
races them in the art of ninjitsu and
that is how they became the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Strait mob splinter
1989 so they decide to help April out in
discovering who's been committing all
these crimes but as you imagine they
don't fit in very well we all know this
game the woman over reacts runs away
screaming you're history scum now back
off exercise that right so they get
those famous trench coats and hats that
of course everybody into thinking
they're not Turtles as they come across
for lack of a better name the ninja
district ninja drycleaners ninja shoe
repairs age of video rentals ninja
dentist out you know what the funny
thing is these all sound like movie
titles for like a sci-fi channel ninja
movie week coming soon without ninja
movie bitch ninja Trikke ninja shoe
repair ninja video rental at nips a
dentist
coming this week odd C fee that's why FY
that whistling channel so I guess the
idea is that the niches work for the
shredder and hide in plain sight in the
Ninja District as the shredder keeps a
close eye on his enemies this April
O'Neil is getting closer to my operation
I lay myself for I should not have sent
a punk to do a ninja's job
so April finds a security building in
the Ninja district that just happens to
be the headquarters of the Foot Clan
I got another scientific equipment
company lined up just waiting to be
cleaned out I found him send a camera
crew
all right send a camera crew do hmm
by any chance is dead off so the turtles
follow the clues to where April is being
held and they're attacked by the Foot
Clan which it turns out is just a bunch
of robots robots robots that still use
ninjutsu weapons yeah by this point if
this shredder is seriously wondering why
he didn't just put guns on these guys
hell even old ladies on the street seem
to have guns in this world and yet these
guys are still fighting with sticks and
arrows Ilia technology is nice but a
bullet is still a bullet whoa wait a
minute
hello
looks like somebody's trying to cop a
shell no wonder she keeps getting
kidnapped all the time she's just
looking for a turtle feel down
[Music]
what are they doing down there did the
foot in the middle of escaping suddenly
decided to start sweating to the oldies
[Music]
but the foot escaped underground and
flood the rest of the building as
splitter fears that the shredder might
also be his mortal enemy Oroku Saki
which closes out our first episode and
leads to the next one entitled what I
mean done that hurt is he still wearing
the sharp they're dense milord rope to
get my mind off that you know other than
the farms they strapped to their chests
I have absolutely no idea what makes the
Palestinians tick I don't get it so we
start with the last episode left office
the turtles are trying to find the
shredders giant vehicle called the
Technodrome
what's a Technodrome you might ask
that's a Technodrome what the hell is
the giant eye on the top of that thing
for anyway is it really how the shredder
sees things I always find the draw a
smiley face on there just to complete
the image
and yeah but you didn't know the
Technodrome was a stick shift either
we're finding out so much today so the
shredder goes to visit Krang talking
tumor with arms that sort of sounds like
that grandpa who can only eat applesauce
I am giving you the best technical
knowledge and by the way because people
will kill me if I don't bring it up
again that is Uncle Phil playing the
shredder and yes it is hilarious to dub
The Fresh Prince of bel-air over his
voice no dad stop me I'm gonna tie this
place up with so much litigation that
your grandchildren are gonna need
lawyers so turns out Krang is from
another dimension called Dimension X and
all he wants from shredder is take a
guess
so to sweeten the deal crank exchanges
some information he tells him that the
shredder could just used the mutagen
that was used on the turtles also on his
own henchman what suppose Yoshi had been
near a more power or an the world mutate
my own people the possibilities are
endless
I think I'll do it twice and then never
again oh the possibilities so he steals
two animals from the zoo and talks to
his henchmen to see who's up for a night
of ungodly genetic realignment I need
volunteers I need two of you for an
experiment forget it it will give you
strength and powers dreamed up so what
yeah this is what happens when shredder
uses Craigslist to get his henchmen
wanted fools to join my giant mutant
army of ninjas must like animals so
eventually he gets two volunteers and
turns them into the mutants bebop and
Rocksteady meanwhile the turtles
investigate the zoo robbery and come
across the Technodrome wait a minute how
come the police while investigating the
robbery didn't just oh I don't know look
down the friggin hole did they think
that if they just took a peek for a
second maybe they come across a giant
mechanical Faberge egg of death I mean
just look guys Master Splinter's walking
stick he must be in trouble so the
turtles go inside and come across a
bunch of death machines
so while fighting these killer
appliances Donatello says one of the
straining juice out of context lines
ever turtles fight with honor yes
because that turtle would never knock
down the robots lights dishonourably you
should know that audience something the
biker mice from mars with you
somebody find a device that I guess they
assumed as a bomb get trapped in a
corner with the supposed bomb strapped
into a wall praying it's a bomb and once
you know it it happens to be a bomb
Turtles sheep with honor they'd seen a
splinters been kidnapped and the
shredder reveals himself telling the
truth about his backstory
it was I who made you what you are today
if not for me
Hamato Yoshi whatever happen I followed
okay where is the shredder getting these
cameras I mean it's one thing to have
surveillance cameras but they seem to be
getting shots that nobody could get I
mean it's there just a what cameraman
walking around and everybody's too
polite to point him out
I mean seriously dude how are they
getting these in hindsight I really show
plan this out better Jamar splitter
we're checking out of his dump
so people fit rocks dude he tried to
blast him again but the turtles trapped
them and leave them behind thus ends
episode 2 as we begin the 3rd episode a
thing about rats
this one starts with an inventor named
Baxter Stockman who's created these
robots called mousers that can
apparently hunt down rats anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no place for pests to hide from
my mousers get rid of all rats huh
what are you crazy you want to drive me
out of business you won't make me a
millionaire which is extremely rare in
the world what's wrong with you the
short-sighted fool doesn't know what
he's missing Oh who are you someone who
wants to produce your Mouse's on a vast
scale
now really folks if you're approached by
a person with a business proposition who
looks like Darth Vader mixed with a
cheese grater you probably shouldn't do
business with him just straight up
common sense so Stockman makes a bunch
of these mousers and the shredder sends
them out to kill splinter but the
turtles arrive in time to save it
where'd these metal maniacs come from
where do you think Michelangelo
trademark Baxter Stockman inventions a
division of shredder Co so they go to
April to see if they can figure out
where to find this Baxter guy we're
looking for the genius who built this
his name is Baxter Stockman that's all
you've got to go on a name I mean it's
not like the Internet's been invented
yet
so she finds the information and the
turtles go looking for it but we also
find out that they may not have much
time
don't you wish to see the fruits of your
labor no I'm tired but it will go
he knows too much put him out of the way
I don't know shredder this guy just made
you a death weapon with a warthog a
rhinoceros ninja robots and not once
asked any questions let's say this guy's
worth keeping around what do you want
now
again the Turtles save them in time and
find out that the next Bunch are being
sent to April's apartment where splinter
is also I don't like the sound of that
ropes
oh my god the loss of innocent life lord
knows how many innocent families were in
there now are suddenly dead oh my god
the impact this must have on our heroes
boy they sure don't build them like they
used to
[Music]
inconsiderate bitch what the hell would
you say if you just saw the Hindenburg
disaster uh-oh SpaghettiOs
fuck oh you are a terrible person
so they fine with the shredders hiding
as Michelangelo sneaks in and tries to
stop the master control and get shredder
some credit this time he actually is
using a gun and now we can see why he
never uses it
so Donatello reprograms the mousers to
tear down the house by simply pushing
one button over and over but the
shredder gets away again in the
Technodrome that's the end of the
mousers yes but what about Michelangelo
really splinter you're gonna just stand
there one of your students might be
dying and you're not even gonna give a
gasp of disbelief that seems pretty
soulless I never liked him anyway I care
not for the potty dudes what they see
he's okay as we move on to our next
episode hot rodding teenagers from
Dimension X
isn't that a funky title it just sort of
a side note here most kids saw these
first few episodes on VHS us they didn't
run the first episodes on TV that often
we loved him at all but there was one
major problem with it on this VHS they
got episodes three and four backwards so
they would show hot rodding teenagers
first before they would show the one
with the mousers now with that in mind
just imagine you're a kid and you're
watching this episode without any
knowledge of the Mouser episode you just
saw but like what Baxter comes back
Baxter won't be back for a long time
Michelangelo the authorities didn't
appreciate it when he tried to take over
the city with his Mouser robots and I
didn't appreciate it when they ate my
apartment
Baxter Stockman April's ex-husband okay
well luckily the DVD has been an order
and this one begins with Donatello
putting together the turtle van because
as we heard in the opening Donatello
does machines no not like that you're
gross but shredder has another plan he's
going to open up the portal to Dimension
X and bring some of cranks armies over
which begs the question why he hasn't
just done this before but if I'm gonna
point out the laxen logic in the show
I'm gonna be here forever two soldiers
come out of the portal but so do some
rambunctious kids call the neutrinos
and why is it they look like vanilla ice
if they just got out of trough my god
it's the worst combination possible
beatniks hands hippies so after they get
the van put together the turtles find
out that then when the neutrinos are on
the same side the neutrinos actually
hate Dimension X as it seems to be
nothing but Wars
what is this Dimension X it's grim place
where everybody wants to do you in just
for the crime of being young when will
people realise the importance of
Dimension X Awareness Day why but the
stone warriors from Dimension X find
them and tried to hunt them down we said
we wouldn't let anyone hurt you and we
mean it come on
[Music]
guys you may want to actually fire those
weapons instead of just making laser
sounds with your mouths but the turtles
escape and consult Master Splinter about
what to do next
Turtles we gotta help them do it
don't worry Cala we won't let anything
happen to you
whoa I'm sensing some strange sporadic
sexual tension than the sewers today
turtles fight with jailbait so the
turtles reached the Technodrome enter
how do they just drive the van hundreds
of feet underground what are their like
tours that go through there so the
turtles break in and start up a fight
there's a barrel of silicone lubricant
over there um lubricant are you sure
that wasn't intended for a previous
episode but the turtles have to leave to
stop one of the stone warriors weapons
from destroying the city they knock it
out and head back halt which leads to
the final episode in our story arc
shredder and splinter how confusing it
starts out with the shredder appearing
at the Turtles TV saying he has a device
to turn the mutations back to their
original form you know something I never
got what doesn't he just take that big
fucking Technodrome the squashing all
right dudes
let's go find the shredder so they tried
to use one of the leftover neutrinos
cars to get there
but that doesn't seem to work it looks
like we're out of fuel
what sort of juice does this crate take
plutonium I think not terrific maybe we
can get a tow to the nearest plutonium
station you don't just walk into a store
and buy plutonium
so Donatella says he can whip up another
form of transportation at Baxter's lab
but bebop and Rocksteady find them and
try to bash their brains out turtles
fight with cement
so as the turtles finally made it to the
Technodrome the shredder at long last
constructs a body for Krang and holy
hell who the fuck design matters that is
like the strangest most bizarre thing
I've ever seen in my life he looks like
a mix between Dolph Lundgren and that
weird giant from Goonies I mean was Boy
George designing a wrestler well that's
going on April goes back to work to try
and get a camera crew to film all the
action I'm trying to get a story for you
try four green maniacs are running loose
in this town and you haven't brought me
diddly squat whoa hey watch the language
pal any further and we be in
fiddle-dee-dee territory but luckily she
uses all her coaxing techniques to get
what she wants
and by coaxing I mean terrorist threats
it's a hyper turtle death ray now order
me a news girl turn this whole place
into a flaming rubble
she's tenacious so crane makes it so
bigger and gets right to destroy the
turtles but just then Donatello arrives
with this new invention come on guys
welcome aboard the Turtle blimp well I
hate so he took a piece of equipment the
size of a counter made a frigging bullet
out of it
he's like the MacGyver of gods so two of
them sneak into cranes body and try to
find the device to shrink him down there
it is let's cut it out of there so crash
winds down but the shredder whips out
his ray and gets ready to turn them back
into ordinary Turtles well gang looks
like it's back to old pet shop for us
far from it tonight I dine on turtle
soup with pillowy mounds of mashed
potatoes
so the Rey is destroyed but the turtles
decide it's time to stop a shredder once
and for all
so Donatello did I mention those
machines figures out the alien
technology and such the Technodrome
itself into Dimension X turtles
unrealistically master alien technology
with honor
I love when the shredder is just a whiny
bitch that's what he's the funniest i
wanna conquer now did be my ass and
those are the first five Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles cartoons are they silly
yes but what's it worth the kind of plot
there's a lot of good fourth wall jokes
and the animation on the action scenes
is actually pretty impressive at the
time it's definitely clumsy but there's
a lot of wrong voices coming out the
wrong Turtles and there's a lot of plot
threads they also don't make a lot of
sense but the timing was pretty good but
it's definitely however for my money
they still got some good lasting good
action up hits kid shows go it's stupid
but it's enjoyably stupid and a ton of
fun to watch if you ever feeling
nostalgic for some awesome turtle action
this is the place to go so thanks for
watching my first Raiders of the story
arc I hope you enjoyed it and hey next
month is January you know what that
means
that's the news and I am out of here
[Music]
turtles fight with honor